I mentioned Doug Gottlieb he was with
CBS for a couple of years and stopped in
last week had some fun she and Doug poor
he was leaving for Fox where he was
going to do some radio and TV and I said
to Seaton we should probably put
together a promo for Doug Gottlieb
leaving CBS and joining the Fox Sports
Radio line up the most powerful lineup
in all of sports radio and this is for
Doug Gottlieb get ready April 24 we've
got a brand new show I can't thank you
enough for everything you done for me
unless my craw I mean God God leave
comes to Fox Sports Radio for one day
and one day only April 25th Oklahoma
State here comes Doug godly first of all
it's one of the top six jobs in college
back the second bone this is the most
efficient it's home but April 24th get a
taste of the Doug Gottlieb experience
women poker it's a Yiddish term it means
family that's not blessed April 25th
deuces gone it's open but April 24 hard
on one day that was a good day was it
not people make the place the jug
Gottlieb show exclusively for three
hours I'm so happy to be a place and
then never again the fact is he has
tinkered with jobs and then changed his
mind last time that's why he is where he
is this is Fox Sports Radio the one day
home of the judge
Jack me waiting doug is amazing oh
that's amazing oh but it's but it's a
tree it's what should I have not been
offered the job so I mean I've talking
about job yesterday but okay okay they
didn't close to doug gottlieb report
that got we've interviewed with Oklahoma
State yesterday and stillwater you you
it was a full interview right yeah okay
yeah Oh Franco well what did they want
to know from you um I think they want to
know outside of the person and I would
say the personality and the salesman
that I am you know how and why why I
wanted you and how I could lead the
basketball program if offered will you
accept well it's not that easy I mean
yeah there's some other issues there I
mean you have to have budgeting not just
for me but yeah you know in order to
hire somebody who hasn't been a head
coach for you got to put together a
staff that fills in the hold the things
you don't know but if everything was
right yeah yeah mammoth that there are
two places down on earth that I feel a
whole I feel like I can be me and one is
orange county Blackie's Beach Airport
beach with Fox Sports and the other is
Stillwater Oklahoma and I know that that
might be weird to people but it just it
it just it gets inside your blood and
when you get back there you realize how
much kinder people can be how much more
investor they are in the school and you
as a person it really made like look I
was a good player I could really pass
the best I could really lead so I wasn't
the greatest players ever played
oklahoma state i'll put myself anywhere
near that's that pantheon but but the
way in which people greet me talk about
me talk to me it's awesome and you have
to remember that it wasn't just read
Underwood is left k be left oklahoma
city ok those same fans feel scorn that
there's that people are saying there's
something wrong with the place that you
call home I want to run back to that
place even if i have to leave Southern
California to do it because that's my
home and because I want to be on that
side by leading that basketball program
back to
so it's either joining cowherd or the
Cowboys like if you put it that way yes
you point out like all honesty Clay
Travis you to cower to me that that's
that's death row and that's the best
radio net nationally Atlanta that's ever
been put together it's really really
amazing stuff and I mean that's how
input amazing the Oklahoma State job is
to me that I legitimately believe that's
a game changer in terms of national
sports radio you and Collin have been
crushing both each other and national
radio for years and to book end it with
me and clay is awesome all right let's
get to last night's games okay what was
the big takeaway from last night um well
it feels like there was a separation
there between Kansas and not just in
Purdue but can't just look the part of a
potential national champion you know if
you know Gonzaga's got a chance play for
national championship I mean boy the
bracket open wide open and and they
didn't they didn't look great they just
care I think the big takeaway though it
end of game situations asters and how
what is that what are you doing for
seven or eight months that you don't
have a better plan Arizona has to win
that game down there the better team
they have an eight-point lead that have
the ball they have to win that game and
I feel terrible for Sean Miller because
I think in terms of implementing a game
plan teaching fundamentals he's an
indefatigable recruiter like all the
check check check check but their their
inability to manipulate a good zone the
last time out he used he ran a play for
juice and wrist which it was like the
fourth best player on the floor hits the
side of the backboard on a hook shot and
then they can't get a stop and they
can't score a bucket they have to win
that game West Virginia I mean that
that's somebody said it's a benny hill
music on Twitter I mean that was that
was comical even even even Michigan John
Beilein who is a coaching like he's
coaching legend legend emeritus their
last possession would find the next to
last possession was a disaster i think
end of game situations is
been really disappointing the execution
or maybe it's been amazingly lack
thereof some of these games yeah and I
that was my takeaway I went you have all
of these timeouts and then you have no
timeouts 30 seconds to go you should you
should know what you're doing that
that's where you have these coaches and
you know attention to detail and I was
shocked at what Arizona didn't do West
Virginia take a to get something put a
little pressure on him I you know
Michigan I was okay with it wasn't great
it almost went down he'd made a shot
prior to that I would like to have
something more but it feels like it's a
layup or a long three that's what
college basketball is known in the final
seconds and that's where you when you
hear people say you know this is a Steph
Curry ization of college basketball
right is that guys guys will settle we
saw this in you know Vanderbilt game
right when they play northwestern we're
right with a chance it just driven the
ball instead he stops for 25 foot really
but yeah like whatever like coaches and
by the way I just a college coaches are
pretty amazing people like Mike Weitz
coaching tonight from Florida and he'd
been talked me on the phone for the last
two days about interviewing about
planning and gave me a guide in terms of
the first hundred one things I presented
yesterday with the first hundred days
now the first 10 days in office all the
things can you do and and like I'm like
Michael shouldn't be preparing your
teams like nah man I want you to get
this so college coaches are awesome and
they all sit around they talk about they
draw things on napkins like no Doug
darling that Doug at Florida running
that if Florida loses to Wisconsin yeah
you're going to get a lot of grief from
the Gator fans because yeah what that
Mike's team was unprepared yes because
what you might goes me one because he
plays noon ball every day and I came
down to one of their games and I carried
them a noon ball and so which I could
carry your team but all you want to do
is shoot free throws because you can't
move anymore so anyway the point is like
part of what makes basketball great is
all of us seeing plays and draw them on
napkins and and and loving the execute
like last year the national championship
game was decided based upon X perfect
execution of a final play if you go back
and watch Villanova and
they they ran that play about nine times
in the regular season and what Jay
Wright would do is he called timeout at
the end of the first half just so he
could set up his last second plate so
that they had repetitions meaning in
game repetition and then in the biggest
moment of the season they meet they
actually ran the Big East tournament and
Scott screwed up but they ran in the
National change of the game and it was
executed perfectly you it's a hard
juxtaposition to then defend college
coaches and we see the lack of execution
some of its the players but some of its
man we gotta have a better plan here
he's Doug Gottlieb working for Fox
Sports Radio at least for now joining us
on the Dan Patrick show the what happens
tonight for Wisconsin's interesting you
know i do think florida's better i think
baylor beat South Carolina I think the
big thing is that the bracket vets in
Memphis should be in New York City from
you know it's Carolina and Kentucky and
UCLA that belongs at msg so that's how
people talk about receiving the
tournament forget receding relocate
those sites you know no one would care
baylor in those schools and in florida
were in memphis UCLA kentucky is the
prize fight right and UCLA went in there
TJ leaf the other freshmen the people
don't talk about had an amazing game I
just think the difference is Lonzo ball
I think the Aaron Fox has some form
those are fosters the better defender
great driver but there's there's an
elegance Alonso ball and the Navarre
ball is crazy and we shouldn't put a
microphone and burn his face but watch
his son play there's just a difference
there and he makes plays he finds ways
to win games I think you Shelli wins
that game and I think they face Carolina
to go to follow for give me an update
before I let you go with Georgetown what
do you what do you think is Patrick
Ewing on the radar on the short list or
are they going to go outside the box
here I just we talked about last time I
did think it was time to make a change I
looked at Ewing is paid his dues in
terms of being an NBA bench big question
will be recruiting you know you got to
get better players you got to have a
plan and recruiting and as much as all
of us grew up watching Pat and look
he'll walk into a gym and everybody know
Pat Ewing end of the day you got it you
know you got to have foot so
you got to have you got to have an army
I mean what I've been able to build us
because i have a brother's been in it
for 20 years I my dad was in for 50
years I have former teammates that are
in the AU circuit we got an army I think
my question for Pat Ewing would be does
he have the energy to get out and
recruit does he have an army and does he
you know does he have a plan in place to
execute because the press conference is
cool everybody feels good the press
comps and you got to go out and get
players win games and really what's been
missing they've missed on far too many
players within the within a closed
radius to to DC more likely to happen
Patrick Ewing goes back to his alma
mater Steve Alford goes back to his alma
mater Doug Gottlieb goes back to his
alma mater I've been told The Steve
Alford thing is done so i would say
that's the most likely but the most fun
would be Doug Gottlieb actors all minor
cuz cuz dan we're gonna we're gonna
bring the danettes in we're going to
show if you guys been to stillwater yeah
i dominated there when did you go to
stillwater I i went to eskimo joe's and
nearly lit the bar on fire with coach
Jones in and Mike Gundy Wow and Alan I
was back there when Robin Ventura was
still at Oklahoma State I put an on an
aerial display there at Gallagher I've
arena I did a it a story on Coach aibu
in Stillwater long long time ago I'm
well versed in Oklahoma City I can't I
can't walk down the street in Stillwater
I just can't who do you think's bigger
in Stillwater mariya 163 what are you 62
so I spent a minute who's a better
harder in Stillwater if you had my
shooting ability you might be playing
how we go I would still be playing you
would go game i'll be a 40 would be a 41
year old backup point guard you have
been obvious you would be the white mint
card you would be you'd be right up
there doing incredible i physco yeah
yeah i mean he doesn't age all right
button so the offered deal is done in
your opinion that he's going to Indiana
yes okay safe travels back let us know
if you're still with this lineup here or
you've decided to join the Cowboys
you got it thank you Doug thanks dad so
godly the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience